para el ángulo agudo que es este que
tenemos aquí abajo el seno de va a ser
igual a 5 entre raíz cuadrada de 41 y la
cota en gente de hacer igual a 8 decimos
encuentre los valores de las otras
igualdades trigonométricas para resolver
esto quiero usar zocato a nuestro
neumónico para recordar las definiciones
de cada identidad trigonométricas vamos
a escribirlo soja
y todas
nos dice que el seno del ángulo que nos
interesa que es el va a ser igual al
cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa si
vemos este ángulo en el cateto opuesto a
este ángulo
es este que vale 5 entre la hipotenusa
que es el lado opuesto a este ángulo
recto
y vemos que es raíz de 41 así que aquí
tenemos información redundante ya que
nos están dando también en el problema
aquí vamos a escribirlo de todas maneras
esto es igual a 5
entre la hipotenusa que es raíz de 41
ahora pensemos en el recíproco del seno
que es la co secante de ccoo secante de
cómo es el recíproco vamos a invertir
estos elementos de manera que nos queda
que es la hipotenusa entre el cateto
opuesto y como tenemos estos valores
simplemente los ponemos aquí va a ser la
consecuente de igual a raíz de 41 el
valor de la hipotenusa entre el valor
del cateto opuesto que es 5
ahora nos toca revisar el coseno de aquí
el mónico nos dice que el coseno de iu
en este caso vamos a escribirlo por acá
con seno de e
es igual al cateto adyacente a entre la
hipotenusa vemos el cateto adyacente de
e es esta esta línea que va de el ángulo
e al ángulo f y está marcada por esta
etiqueta que dice a así que aquí no
conocemos el valor todavía más adelante
lo resolveremos vamos a dejar está aquí
ya que todavía no conocemos cuáles son
el valor que tiene
pero la hipotenusa si sabemos que es la
hipotenusa es raíz de 41 así que aquí lo
sustituimos como raíz de 41
aprovechamos que tenemos ya el coseno
para encontrar su recíproco que es la
secante lo escribimos secante de e el
recíproco vamos a invertir los valores
va a ser la hipotenusa entre el cateto
adyacente conocemos el valor de la
hipotenusa que es raíz de 41 y aún
desconocemos cuál es el valor del
adyacente o de este lado que también
coincide que tiene la letra minúscula
así que va a ser esto la hipotenusa
entre a para que quede más claro aquí
voy a señalar con respecto al ángulo e
cuál es el cateto opuesto en este caso
este lado es el opuesto
o puesto
este que lado que está opuesto al ángulo
recto es la hipotenusa y este no cambia
siempre va a ser este la hipotenusa
hipotenusa
a este lado que es etiquetado como a es
el lado adyacente al ángulo adyacente
entonces quedamos que nos falta nuestra
última igualdad o nuestro último par de
igualdades que es con respecto a la
tangente nuestro armónico nos dice todas
está en gente de tangente de igual al
cateto opuesto entre el cateto adyacente
/ a
sabemos el cateto opuesto conocemos el
lado es este vale 5
aquí sustituimos entre a que es el
adyacente y aquí me falta poner una está
decente y no sabemos todavía cuánto vale
este lado así que le dejamos la a
aprovechando que ya tenemos la tangente
vamos a encontrar su recíproco que es la
co tangente la escribimos la cota en
gente del ángulo e es el recíproco de la
tangente por lo tanto va a ser a entre o
adyacente entre opuesto que es igual a
la literal a del lado adyacente entre 5
ahora necesitamos encontrar cuál es el
valor de a para poder terminar de
encontrar bien estos valores en los
datos del problema nos dice que la cota
en gente de vale 8 decimos y aquí
acabamos de calcular que la contingente
de es igual al adyacente entre 5 por lo
que vamos a poner que esto es igual a
los datos que nos están dando en el
problema que esto es igual a 8 decimos
cómo podemos resolver esto bueno tenemos
por este lado entre 5 es igual a 8
decimos podemos ver que este se puede
reducir ya que tiene un factor en común
tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador pero también lo que puedo
hacer es despejar a como lo despejó
bueno voy a multiplicar 5 en ambos lados
de la ecuación me va a quedar que esto
se cancela 8 por 540 decimos es igual a
40 decimos
puede intentar 10 va a ser igual a 4 a
es igual a 4 y ya que tenemos el valor
de a pues lo que resta es sustituir esto
en las igualdades trigonométricas que
acabamos de encontrar por lo que la
tangente de va a ser igual a 5
entre 4 la cota en gente de ella
habíamos visto que era 8 décimos pero
aquí sustituimos y nos queda que es
cuatro quintos si multiplicamos el
numerador y el denominador por 2 nos va
a quedar que esto es igual a 8 décimas
por lo que estas dos son equivalentes
también vamos a sustituir está en el
coseno de de manera que el coseno de va
a ser igual a 4 entre raíz de 41 y
finalmente la secante de va a ser igual
a raíz de 41
entre 4 y con esto tenemos resueltas las
seis igualdades trigonométricas que nos
piden ahora podemos verificar que
efectivamente este valor de igual a 4 es
correcto si usamos el teorema de
pitágoras que nos dice que la suma de
los cuadrados de los catetos va a ser
igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa tengo
el cuadrado del cateto opuesto es 5 al
cuadrado más el cuadrado del cateto
adyacente 4 al cuadrado esto debe ser
igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa que
es raíz de 41 al cuadrado
nos da 5 x 5 es 25 + 4 x 4 16 esto debe
ser igual a 41 y efectivamente 25 16 es
igual a 41 por lo que esto verifica que
nuestro resultado de a es correcto